c'est la première étape vers un
troisième déconfinement lundi les
écoliers feront leur retour dans les
salles de classe une rentrée encadré par
un protocole sanitaire stricte et un
renforcement massif des tests
suivront ensuite les collégiens et les
lycéens qui pourront retrouver leur
rétablissement
le 3 mai prochain c'est indispensable
les enfants ont besoin d'écoles les
privés d'école a des conséquences
éducatives sanitaires psychologiques
le but est que les enfants français est
une année d'école la plus normale
possible
le 3 mai une date clé qui devrait aussi
marquer la levée des restrictions de
déplacement journée sur le territoire en
revanche le couvre-feu restera en
vigueur jusqu'à nouvel ordre indiqué
jean castex le premier ministre qui
reste également prudent sur la
réouverture des établissements
accueillant du public nous pour enlever
les contraintes de déplacement en
journée est envisagée sous réserve de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses
cette liste n'est pas définitivement
fixée elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes beaucoup d'incertitudes
demeurent
alors que le niveau de l'épidémie reste
élevée tout comme la pression
hospitalière près de 6000 personnes sont
toujours en réanimation pour un total de
30 mille patients hospitalisés